Johnny Depp loved Johnny Depp prints in
the house Oprah's here how you doing
Oprah is so rich I saw John Kerry
proposing to her just an hour ago okay
and our next presenter is a two-time
Oscar nominee and Oprah's Favorite white
man John Travolta go
the category is Original Score it's the
music you hear that underscores our
company's the action and a film whether
someone is walking down a New York
Street with attitude or the superheroes
chasing the bad guys also with attitude
every emotion is heightened with music
the five nominated composers in this
category have demonstrated their ability
to consistently hit the right note and
they are
Finding Neverland by Yan AP cosmic
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban
by John Williams
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate
Events by Thomas Newman
The Passion of the Christ by John Debney
the village by James Newton Howard
and the Oscar goes to yon apks Marek for
Finding Neverland
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Yan ap Cosmo
I cannot tell you how happy I am and
thank you Academy finding Netherland was
a great adventure and I'm so proud to be
part of it
Marc Foster should be here Marc thank
you for your subtle minds for your
incredible talent also Richard is here
Richard glassing a man who truly
understands power of music I'm very
thankful for this as well and then my
wife Olivia who always surprises me with
her intellectual passion and incredible
taste she's responsible for many good
knows I I've written and my friend and
agent Dan he's a greenspan thank you so
much who has left many people but I'm
too overwhelmed to really go go go on I
should certainly take opportunity to the
first person in the room to thank Harvey
Weinstein for his support and I and and
very thankful as well for supporting
Finding Neverland and my case musicians
usually forgotten but extraordinary
people who made music alive and without
them the best music just doesn't exist
so thank you very much my collaborators
in Poland and here in America
Christopher Rafal Leszek thank you so
much I'm very very honored